When a normal stress ball was placed into
the Clockworks on Fine, the result was a stress
ball that, at random intervals between a minute
and five minutes in length, hurls itself at
the face of the person in closest proximity
to it.
If the face is covered or otherwise protected,
it will alternatively aim for the stomach
or crotch.
Object secured and destroyed.
However, on Very Fine, it became a palm-sized
teddy bear, stuffed with plastic beads.
The object is animate and seems to have a
fascination with cuddling/nuzzling ankles
and infrequently requests signs of affection.
Object contained for further study.
One doctor noted, “And whoever decides to
look into this farther… be nice to the little
guy, all right?”